hey guys this is dennis the founder of
think care and i'm david griffin your
resident comic book and video game guru
and this is our review of agents of
shield episode 16. end of the beginning
end of the beginning
and beginning of the end wait something
like that so
i thought it was a decent episode
you know i enjoyed some of it some parts
i didn't like i did think it was better
than the the
last episode which was the sif episode i
know you like that one a lot such a good
episode um
i like this one more because it actually
has to deal with an overall storyline
they bring back characters we've seen
before storylines we've we've heard
about before
uh i like bill baxton
as a guest star yeah what did you think
it was solid it was nice seeing um every
time we see uh patterson mike mike
patterson
peterson mike peterson you know the
whole death lock program he interests me
i wish we got to see more of him he's
just kind of that
guy in the background causing chaos you
know possibly being manipulated all this
stuff going on with him he always scars
on he looks messed up you know but i
mean i really like seeing the scenes
with him um of course the whole big
thing i guess at the end is you know
with um uh melinda may uh agent may
being discovered that's a more
interesting part of the show yeah
because it's like who's she working for
like again you know i speculated that we
don't think she's a villain no probably
working for somebody
yeah fury probably fury i'm sure
i kind of probably see sam jackson
before the end of the season again you
know this is like as a guest appearance
uh it was good a lot of good character
actors they brought i never remember
anybody's name but the woman he's got
the the dimple in her chin really pretty
you know miss hand hand agent hand like
she's really good i like her as an
actress the guy who does the scotch
second reminds actors and all these
great character actors this season um uh
and this was a well-rounded episode i
thought not great but i thought it was
well-rounded okay well speaking of uh
death lock yeah what do you think of the
costume because i think the costume
looks kind of cheesy to be honest
yeah like i like his mechanical stuff
yeah but i mean just as a whole when you
see him it just looks like
a little too homemade for me yeah yeah
it's it's okay i mean it's
it's so hard because like superhero
costumes when you see them on in a comic
book it looks certain away when you see
them you know on tv they can either look
cheesy but
it's okay i don't mind it i don't know
yeah
it's one of the things i think
that's hard for me to to really get into
the show is
with the character of skye
and the character of ward
one i don't really get too much into
their characters especially
and two i really don't buy their
romance other it's one of those
situations where it's
here's a good-looking girl there's a
good-looking guy
so you're just expected you know kind of
like a in thor remember with thor and
natalie portman as jane foster you're
just like oh
they're in love right right
relationship's way better than thor too
because you have a little more time you
can't just like throw like oh they're
two good-looking people they must fall
in love yeah it's a little too
so for for a ward to be all like the
protective over sky and like
shoot the supposed clairvoyant the fake
clairvoyant apparently right over you
know that was they're hinting that that
was the main reason i said he died
i don't know if anybody noticed him but
that's uh worm tongue from lord of the
rings great british character actor
awesome actor i can't remember his name
but you know if you ever watch lord of
the rings he's worm worm tongue and i
was like oh it sucks they killed him
that was interesting i didn't expect
ward to shoot him um
that was interesting but again like i
said wards characters not quite deep
enough but they are trying to give these
people more backstory with each passing
week so it's just it's a slow burn i
mean we're in episode 16 now it took a
long time but these these trump to give
the show credit these chunks of episodes
since sif and all these episodes are
better than the first half of the season
yes except for the pile i didn't mind
the pile i thought pile was okay well
yeah i mean the pilot you don't have any
too many you know like you don't know if
it's going to be episodic or not because
the first episode's the first episode
you don't know if this is okay this is
going to continue to yeah further
storyline which it did which i'm
thankful for they have been planting
seeds they just have been planting them
very slowly and yeah
you know taking their time and i i think
that's it the thing is
there are other shows that you know do
the same thing maybe they plant seeds or
i mean i'm not going to try too deep but
like you know bulldog empire you know
which was like breaking bad there's
stuff that happens like underneath the
layers just building and building when
this show does it doesn't feel like
anything's happening even when it's
trying to and i realize it's a different
kind of show but like i'd like i'm glad
that we are seeing more but it did take
a long time for this to happen i will i
have to give this show credit these
episodes are better than they were in
the past yeah i think ever since that
one
the couple of episodes with the
sky getting shot
those were better for me you know
uh so but i do like you know bill pax i
think he's a great addition too he's got
his character has a personality and
and i think you know titus walliver was
in this episode he was uh he's people
know him from lost and deadwood
he was the guy that got shot that put
the tracker on deathlock in this episode
so i like these editions especially
because yeah a lot of good character and
of course i'm when i'm doing this review
i'm saying stuff hey it's that guy from
that thing you know i mean there are a
lot of actors in this uh episode like
that and a lot of good character actors
so i mean i thought this was
one of the stronger episodes recently
except i do like the sif episode um but
uh no this one was good this one was a
shield episode it didn't rely on
you know another marvel character to
come in and hold you know be a crutch
this was a shield episode well what i'm
interested in
is
i've already seen captain america too it
comes out this
this friday right right
there are significant things that happen
okay
within the shield organization in
captain america too i'm not going to
give any spoilers
that
have to
affect the show i mean i just can't see
it not affecting the show
and then there are certain things in
this episode where i saw
i was like oh maybe that has something
to do with it but i don't know right i'm
not 100 you know because you do have
this whole
melinda may working for someone else i
have you know thoughts on that from what
you've seen in captions yeah also the
victoria hand
and how she now wants to
you know take down agent coulson yeah
so we'll see next week
if yeah i'm seeing it friday so we'll
see yeah yeah but we'll we'll see next
week next week's episode oh it's a
shield
is there an episode it is next week yeah
no break no more breaks um to see if
that
is
actually is affected and then is that
going to make people go see captain
america
or not i think
people will see captain america no
matter what no matter what overseeing
shield well of course so i'm guessing
that they will
take into account what happens
in uh in captain america two
and have it play into
agents of shield right yeah so i'll be
curious to see that next week yeah i
mean when i see captain america then
watch the new shield episode on tuesday
but i'm wondering are they going to put
like a few
a collage of scenes together that show
what happens in captain america too so
that you'll know
cause
it's it's a big leap it's a big leap for
what happened but it's better than the
thor where they just like show up in
london be like oh thor did all this and
then they just leave like that was kind
of useless i hope they do more with it
like well this is directly involved with
shield so
all right
it's it's hard to avoid that's my
question i don't know what the timelines
are in terms of
of this where the show is and where
captain america 2 is supposed to be
taking place
but yeah
it's pretty big stuff that you can't
overlook right i don't know what do you
think of i don't know if you read these
the uh article and interview with uh the
executive producers for agents of shield
uh marisa takaren and
her husband
jed whedon you know we both really liked
them as writers i think they did a
really good rewatch of spartacus right
now yeah they did a really good job with
as far as godzilla arena i thought they
did a good job with the dollhouse
however
you know
we are we have been critical of agents
of shield they came out in an interview
and they were trying to defend
themselves saying yeah we're taking you
know our time and you know
you know people can't expect uh
a marvel movie every week but i think
that's kind of a weak argument because
people are not expecting that maybe a
small percentage are but most of us are
just looking for
good characters good story lines we
aren't looking for a marvel like a giant
budget thing people you know
you and mike do the review for arrow
that obviously is a very small budget
compared to the same back alley in
vancouver every episode yeah right yeah
so but people are really into it and
support they are not critical of arrow
no and it has to do with storyline and
character yeah i i care about what the
characters are going through on a weekly
basis i want it and it's not always
perfect they don't always do it perfect
but they just make the characters
interesting i think she'll just feels so
generic
and spartacus no not everybody has seen
that but spartacus the characters were
very interesting in spartacus especially
in the you know the guys that you read
in the second third and fourth season
which they were all producers on judd
whedon in them like they were it was
very interesting i think i'm assuming
their stars gave them more freedom to
kind of do what they wanted i mean this
is this is marvel's baby this is abc
this is a 22 episode season i wonder how
like
tightly they're being watched because i
mean jedwin's never been a showrunner
before even though his brother is is
obviously joshua yeah but you wonder i
i don't know i hope they can come back i
mean if they do with season two i don't
think abc's gonna let the show fail i'll
be interested to see what that's gonna
be like
i have i have a feeling that this show
is gonna get pretty good
in season two but all
the fans are and we won't be around
watching it the fans will be gone by
then yeah i was like are you watching
shield it's so good now because the
ratings have gone down
so much this episode was lowest yeah
well when you keep skipping weeks right
you know and whether i know some of you
didn't like you know sifts let me do but
i mean sif either if you didn't like the
episode or not a couple weeks ago it was
a big episode one of their biggest and
then they just
take a two-week break after all that
momentum it's like why would you do
something like that i don't know oh
come on abc now so yeah i mean overall i
i did enjoy parts of this episode you
know and i thought it was a decent
episode and i think there's stuff there
that they can build on especially the
end stuff with melinda may that stuff
interests me she's a more interesting
character and the whole
organization of shield and and then
after you guys see captain america two
then you'll come back and
you'll see what i'm talking about yes i
haven't seen it yet i'm still waiting
all right guys you can post your
comments below on the website
thinkhero.com or on our youtube channel
thinkhero pro make sure you subscribe to
that well you also can find us on
twitter talk to dennis franklin myself
about uh agents of shield uh michael and
i dennis already saw captain america
mike and i are going to see it on friday
so fill you in on all of our thoughts
and everything i'm sure dennis now do a
review of that uh you can find us at
think hero i'm at griffinde and we have
a facebook page that's facebook.com
think hero fans make sure you like that
page
and share our videos on twitter and
facebook and all that stuff